attention citizens of gridiron heights
there will be some new rules this season
first off no taunting what's up football
nerds i got you no cat oh
one time you play often also no haunting
hey man great job out there you're the
future of our league
thank you ghosts shouldn't have to say
this one but no cannibalism whoa welcome
to the lion king have dinner or become
dinner none of your precious little
parodies hey yo this is lee
you'll always remember the day you
almost caught pat in my home at last my
final four and now i'm the perfect qb no
shenanigans no hijinks no capers of any
kind you must vote out the impossible
bears
that child is going to die i knew you
down there somewhere your mom and dad
i'm not enjoying camp anymore
phoebe is getting it together
turtle turtle glam
this year we're going to be calm orderly
and boring the things people love about
football thank you tuesdays this fall on
bleacher report
all right let's try another take where
everyone applaud oh sir we were alive
you can make cartoons live oh god